in den Schweizer Gefängnissen gibt es
bereits ein paar Jahren einen Wandel
Häftlinge nahezu ohne Kontakt zur
Außenwelt das soll bald Geschichte sein
das Internet soll dabei helfen Bea so
möchte er sich nennen denn er will
anonym bleiben ist seit fünf Jahren in
Haft ich bin eigentlich promoviert der
Historik hier und arbeite seit Jahren in
der Gärtnerei und deshalb ist es
natürlich für mich auch schön wenn ich
mal wieder so ein bisschen intellektuell
etwas tun kann das bedeutet schon sehr
viel hier in dieser Zelle in der JVA
Witz wie hat sich Bert eingerichtet der
Computer mit Internet gehört seit
einigen Wochen dazu sondern Freizeit
übersetzt er ein Comic finanzieren muss
er sich wie alle Häftlinge Computer und
Internet Zugang selbst durch eine
Whitelist wird der Zugang nur zu
bestimmten Seiten freigeschaltet ist das
System wirklich sicher
diese Angst besteht natürlich aber das
System wird ja so gebaut sein dass
eigentlich immer verfolgt werden kann
was getan wurde und wenn ein Verdacht
besteht das kriminelle Handlungen
stattgefunden haben dann wird das
ausgewertet und es kann dann sein dass
in einem solchen Mann dann der Zugang
verwehrt wird die JVA ist ein offenes
Gefängnis für erwachsene Männer im
Kanton Bern das Besondere die Häftlinge
können sich auf dem Gelände relativ frei
bewegen und haben alle einen eigenen
Schlüssel für ihre Zellen nur nachts
werden sie von den Wörtern
eingeschlossen Leon macht im Gefängnis
eine Ausbildung zum Schlosser die Praxis
findet im Gefängnis statt die Schule ist
eine öffentliche und außerhalb der JVA
um zu lernen braucht Leon das Internet
allerdings hat seine Zelle noch keinen
Anschluss er muss noch in den Medienraum
es ist auch eine eine Chance dass sie
vom gefängnisausfall aus einer Lehrer
machen darf
ja
[Musik]
und ich halte ich muss
ich muss mich einfach anpassen mit dem
was es zum Verfügung gibt
ich muss mich anpassen wie ich einfach
kurz darauf gut zu machen und Leon nutzt
seine Chance er ist Klassenbester
Brigitte spiletta ist die
Bildungsverantwortliche hier im
Gefängnis sie hilft und berät die
Häftlinge vor allem wenn es um
berufliche Fragen geht
es gehört der kontrollierte und halt
auch ja wirklich kontrollierte Einsatz
vom Internet das ist wichtig und wir
haben ja dadurch dass das eine weitlist
ist eigentlich und gewisse seitenge
blockt sind auf diese sowieso
grundsätzlich nicht drauf kommen ist die
Gefahr auch etwas kleiner aber sie sehen
die Prinzessin genauso gestellt dass wir
immer ein Auge drauf haben können was
sie machen den Internet Zugang müssen
die Gefangenen selber bezahlen aber dass
die Häftlinge überhaupt die Möglichkeit
haben sich digital vorzubilden ist für
die Bildungsverantwortliche eine
Selbstverständlichkeit wir haben ein
bewerbungsmodul wo die Gefangenen die
müssen Job suchen die müssen Ihren
Lebenslauf herstellen ihre Zeugnisse
einscannen und so und da haben wir gute
Rückmeldungen dass es ihnen viel
gebracht hat gerade die Gefangenen die
vor ihrer Haft Entlassung stehen müssen
sich im Internet einigermaßen auskennen
weiß espeleta
ich denke es ist wirklich sehr wichtig
weil sonst wird sie haben eh einen
Stempel da wo stetig war im Knast und
wenn sie dann die Fähigkeiten haben fast
gleich wieder draußen das nützt ihnen
sehr viel Arnold studiert in seiner
Freizeit an der Fernuniversität Hagen
Psychologie tagsüber muss er arbeiten
wie alle Männer hier im Gefängnis Arnold
stand Namensschilder die er vorher im
Computer programmiert hat
haben des Namens ich glaube das ist eine
neue Mitarbeiterin aber ich weiß es
nicht
es ist eine Beschäftigung sind
Zeitvertreib es ist
nicht die monotons der Arbeit die es
gibt also es hat schon ein bisschen
einen Abwechslung drinnen das Gefängnis
ist gerade im Umbau daher hat auch
Arnold noch kein Internetzugang in
seiner Zelle aber es klappt auch so
ja es gibt ein Internetraum da muss man
sich vorher Einschreiben und dann kann
man mit einem USB-Stick dorthin sich
etwas runterladen also in meinem Fall
für mein Studium und dann komme ich mit
dem USB-Stick hierher und
kann den hier dann
einstecken und so die Daten übertragen
was ich vor allem jetzt im Moment sehr
viel mit Literatur für meine
Masterarbeit machen
Arbeiten im Netz ist die eine Sache für
Arnold bedeutet das Internet auch ein
Stück digitale Freiheit schon einfach
ein bisschen Kontakt zu haben auch wenn
man im Fernsehen einfach irgendwelche
Programme Reportagen sieht dass man im
Internet nachschauen kann gibt es noch
mehr Informationen gibt es eigentlich
Artikel dazu und so weiter das mache ich
nicht sehr gern es gibt ein bisschen
einen mir einen Connex zur Außenwelt
surfen hinter Gittern da kommt dann
schon die Frage auf ist das noch Strafe
die Strafe ist ja der Freiheitsentzug
also sie werden in ihrer persönlichen
Freiheit werden sie eingeschränkt sie
können nicht sagen und tun und lassen
was sie wollen aber dann hört es
eigentlich schon auf mit Strafen also
ich muss ja die Leute nicht bestrafen
indem dass ich Ihnen die Digitalisierung
vorenthalte und sie eigentlich ja zu
digitalen Analphabeten lassen damit es
dazu nicht kommt gibt es in der Schweiz
bereits seit 2017 in einigen
Gefängnissen Internet Zugänge für
Gefangene seit November auch in den
Zellen der JVA witzwil Berlin testet
seit Dezember Computer in der Zelle als
nächstes Bundesland will
Baden-Württemberg nachziehen Vorbild ist
die Schweiz
es geht gerade nicht darum die
Haftbedingungen schöner zu machen es
geht darum im Sinne einer
Resozialisierung also sich später
straffrei wieder in die Gesellschaft
einzufügen auch vorzubereiten auf dem
Leben außerhalb der Haft zudem eben
heute auch die Nutzung digitaler Medien
dazugehört Wert ist froh in seiner
Freizeit arbeiten zu können den
Übersetzungsauftrag hat er von Freunden
bekommen
als die Anfrage kam ob ich da mithelfen
könnte dass man sich irgendwie doch noch
als Teil der Gesellschaft fühlt auch
wenn man weggesperrt ist es geht noch
Leute die die sind das sind Freunde die
Vertrauen einen die möchten einem in
diesen Projektteams dabei haben und das
ist schon ich sag's mal so
Selbstbewusstsein ganz ganz stark wenn
man weiß okay es gibt draußen eine Welt
und ich könnte auch noch ein Teil in
einem kleinen Bereich davon sein nicht
ich bin noch weh ich bin nicht einfach
nur weg eingesperrt und vergessen
sondern man kommuniziert noch man ist
ein Teil davon ein Teil der Gesellschaft
sei nicht vergessen werden das ist für
Beat wichtig denn noch sieben Jahre Haft
liegen vor ihm